[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster i'm konstantine kissin
and this is a show for you if you're
bored with people arguing on the
internet of the subjects they know
nothing about trigonometry we don't
pretend to be the experts we ask the
experts our brilliant guests this week
is a wonderful comedian one of our
absolute favorites Simon Evans thank you
very much thank you very nice to be
Simon Evans destroys trigonometry
that'll be the clip that comes out thank
you so much for coming on the show we've
got so much to talk about but for anyone
who doesn't know who you are yeah just
tell us who are you how are you where
you are what's been your journey through
life I am 54 years old now living in
Hove in South Coast on south coast next
to Brighton with my wife and two kids
I've been a comedian for 22 23 years now
which I sort of got into by accident
really I was planning on a career in
journalism having entered my thirties
really without anything really having
any gears having really bit into my life
and and a newspaper asked me to write an
article about people who were doing
comedy workshops for fun just for
recreational purposes and that began the
sort of train of events which saw me
begin stand-up and somehow it just
clicked so at about the age of 31 I
started doing stand-up and incredibly
somehow you know every time one beam has
given way another one has appeared and
I've lepton to it in time and I'm still
making a living very good so there's so
much going on with comedy right now you
you were performing a comedy unleashed
by the time this video goes out it will
already have happened yes it's a show
that we've talked about we've both
performed there there's been an article
recently they came out about that
there's lots of discussion about free
speech one of the biggest stories I
think that's happened recently has been
the Joe brand case and for anyone who
doesn't know Joe brand made the joke
about how instead of milk shaking I
don't know she said far-right
politicians that you
yeah what we should do instead is for a
battery acid yes and then she was saying
this as part of a comedy performance on
a comedy program yes but I think a lot
of the stuff that came out of that and I
talked about it was to double standards
of left versus right freedom of speech
for comedians freedom of speech in
general the ability to make jokes what
was your take on that situation well
there are a number of salient factors I
think the most obvious one to say is
that yes of course it was a joke but I
think it was a joke which on a moment's
reflection you would see was probably
not an appropriate thing to broadcast on
radio for at a point where tensions were
very high and I think the people half
the reason that milk shaking is such an
effective tool is because it arouses a
brief moment of panic in the victim when
they don't know what's been thrown at
them you know and I think people live in
in genuine fear of being attacked by
something more serious so I think a
moment's reflection would have made
anyone realize that it wasn't an
appropriate thing to broadcast and that
moment should have then been grasped by
the various you know rafts of authority
and editing processes and the producers
and so on who would have mediated
between Joe saying it and the audience
laughing but a little nervously I think
and sort of 24-hour gap at least before
it's broadcast so I certainly don't
blame Joe Brand at all for a misjudgment
or an error of taste or whatever because
as I think we've all discussed before
now if you ought to be able to function
as a comedian you'll have to be able to
cross the line realize you've crossed it
and retreat without having your career
in tatters you know without having a
police investigation people refer to
edgy comedians perhaps without really
considering what the word means well for
me it means the edge of what is
acceptable and you transgress it
occasionally and you play with it even
if you just do a live gig in front of a
comedy club audience every comedian is
always pushing up see where they are
where their collective edges and one or
two people will feel you've crossed it
at any given point and then you come
back and for some people you know making
a joke at the expense of let's say down
syndrome will be something that's beyond
the pale and they just won't accept it
and Frankie Boyle got into trouble with
with a joke like that a few years ago
having done other material in which he
quite literally you know decapitates
politicians and vomits into their riding
trunks you know
you know in these situations so it's not
necessarily I don't think it should be
imposed on Joe brand but having said all
that it was a tiny bit of schadenfreude
that I enjoyed bit in seeing her held
that to account because she herself has
called other people on that kind of
stuff you know she she famously had
Carol Thatcher essentially you know
blackballed from any further employment
prospects at the BBC after an
off-the-cuff remark she made you know in
the greenroom I think a slightly
old-fashioned and misjudged joke that
she made but it wasn't I don't think it
was fueled by hate or any sort of
vicious racism or anything will Joe
brand reported that Carol Thatcher never
worked again whether whether that was
not intended as revenge for Joe brands
quite open loathing for her mother for
Margaret Thatcher I don't know but it
seemed to be an extraordinary
coincidence if it wasn't and and then
she quite recently scolded Ian Hislop of
course live on on have I got news for
you when his luck was essentially
chortling at the notion that a bit of a
sort of clumsy Negro pin the Commons
canteen was on the same level of me to
Horror Story you know there's as the
weinstein revelations and so on it was
all being collected in under the hashtag
me too i think a journalist i come over
as a journalist you know attempted to
grope an MP or vice versa
okay yeah so and it wasn't you know it
was it wasn't like he wasn't saying it
doesn't matter but he was kind of joking
it's not really quite on the same level
as these hollywood revelations and doe
deliver this kind of minute long
monologue telling him that this kind of
thing just wears you down and got a
round of applause but essentially she
was policing his sense of humor and his
sense of proportion and telling him no
this matters well that's all that
everyone else has done a lot of other
people of then police don't know sorry
but when you are a public figure you do
live in fear now of a serious assault on
the street and this kind of thing
doesn't help and if it had been the left
who had been given an opportunity to
castigate a right-wing comedian for
joking about something they would
immediately have you know brought up
Joe Cox murder and so on as as
indications of exactly why these kind of
things are not to be joked about so I
think there has been a huge amount of
hypocrisy but none of it I would say in
all seriousness should hinder any
comedian from cracking any joke they
want to make you know it certainly in
like a non live scenario because it was
then expected that the producers will
clean that up and go actually that on
reflection doesn't really work for us
and so we're just gonna snip it out
which of course they did in the later
editions but maybe it was a discussion
that needed to happen I don't know I
don't know but I don't blame Nigel
Farraj for kicking off because that's
his opportunity of course to play the
game and that is the game we will play
now I do blame certain other comedians
funnily enough who then claimed that
this was hypocritical of Raj because
Faraj had defended called Benjamin over
his rape joke concerning Jess Phipps
because he hadn't Karl Benjamin was with
you Kip who Farraj had left and
regardless of whether you like Ferrari
or not he left you Kip and has said it
has become a den of you know weirdos and
you know quite extremist figures and
indeed it has sort of become a little
bit of an odd it's like a clearinghouse
for disaffected you know Internet
warriors well we've had coloured the
show long before all this controversy
happened Sargon of Akkad which everyone
of course who isn't in the Internet just
finds this absurd well that was his name
from when he was a gaming pianists was
you know I think he was part of game ok
I have no interested in that although
gamergate Sam say is actually the birth
of everything that's happened since
certainly in America you know the whole
of like 4chan and Paul and and the green
frog and and all of this sort of
tongue-in-cheek supportive of Trump and
everything and whether or not that
shades into the actual sort of a
coherent politics of the alright you
know it's a lot of it lodged in that in
that sort of culture war there yeah they
thought these things were all linked up
but South American I used to listen to
some of his podcast and YouTube content
I always found him an annoying pompous
sort of he had a certain kind of
presumption on his part that he was the
smartest guy in the room you know and I
always thought you should maybe look at
getting into some better rooms
how you feel you know raise your game a
little bit it's easy to just talk so
kind of weird you know black death metal
black moss kind of guys you know and
think you're a bit smarter than them and
understand how nationalism really works
or something you know if that's the kind
of company you're keeping that elevate
your status a bit and unfortunately I
think you came a cropper because you
know the mainstream media will just kind
of go you're a lunatic you're a visible
figure and here is your one claim to
fame it was a misjudged rape joke about
a sitting MP and so you're you know
you're no longer fit for purpose well
since you brought that up Simon so yeah
I was just gonna say of a cad fans who I
can already see well yeah well he's been
on the show so who watch ass also I
don't dislike him I just my visceral
reaction I thought was yet very positive
but I don't think it was fair of the
mainstream media to say you are the guy
who cracked that one joke and that is
your entire well this is what I was
going to ask you about and by the way
Carl comes to comedy Unleashed quite a
lot but I be one of them I talked about
this Joe brand thing on the BBC and
stuff and one of the things that people
were saying was well look at Carl
Benjamin right he made a joke yeah and
everyone jumped down his throat yeah and
I guess for me the difficulty is that
it's not so much that he made the joke
and I've said this to Kyle face-to-face
I said I thought that was the wrong
thing to say because he said it to her
yeah and Twitter yeah as opposed to just
making a joke yeah somewhere else it was
much more personal is that the line that
you think about it's very interesting I
mean it's obviously is a different
context and context matters but whether
it makes it better or worse is a really
interesting question isn't it I mean
would it if as a as a comedian I were to
go on heresy and say you know women MPs
are always trying to introduce
legislation about rape to be honest I
look at some of them I wouldn't even
rape her well I think that would be the
end of my career I mean that would be an
absolutely you know in that context and
I would
[Laughter]
and they wouldn't broke us any and then
word would get out from him by Joe brand
[Laughter]
but so in that respect you have to say
well then the you know the context is
presumably yes so but on the other hand
he usually I felt I sort of was
following the debate at the time and if
I remember correctly she was he felt
that she was sort of minimizing and
trivializing and laughing off the notion
that men's sexual health men's threats
that men face and so I need the same
sort of level of protection as women or
whatever and in that context he
obviously felt that the heat was already
raised and that this was the the heat at
the level at which a response like that
was appropriate whereas obviously just
kind of out of the blue and out of
nowhere it wouldn't be context he's kind
of everything in these things and of
course it's the first casualty of war
you know so that's the that is the
tricky aspect of it but I didn't think
it was I don't think it was a great joke
but then I didn't think Joe brands was a
great joke either the reality is it's
not heresy to say that that was the one
thing everyone said that annoy me goes
well you're tuned into a program like
heresy would you expect although there
isn't heresy in front of the radio for
audience that's Orthodox enjoyed it
Nigel Farraj literally deserves to have
life-changing injuries is radio 4 comedy
orthodoxy that is that's as straight
down the line as you can get you know
who said on heresy I don't know I quite
like Nigel Farraj you know he looks like
he'd be a nice bloke to have a point
with you know that would be heresy - you
could have told immediately from the
audience reaction I suspect that you had
now transgressed seriously but you won't
get no because you'll never get booked
together but I was gonna say do you
think there is a bias in comedy Simon
with you know left-leaning liberal
comedians getting the majority of the
airwaves there are all sorts of
different aspects of that question I
think that I do think that the BBC
struggles to find even centrist
comedians I would say I mean that I
don't expect to see right wing like the
kind of old-fashioned you know Jim
Davison or whatever right wing or the
the
these sensibilities and the subtext you
know that you might call racist or
whatever underlying those kind of jokes
but they struggle to find anyone who who
challenges the I guess the kind of
campus politics that seem to dominate
you know the fringes now I'm in the
different context on social media where
I spend far too much time on Twitter
it's obviously part of the of the whole
proposition of Twitter and the whole
dynamics and the algorithms and
everything that drives everything to the
extremes because nobody's interested in
a moderate view people far more likely
to click and repeat and respond and
retweet to anyone kind of going you know
I have insanely mad you know this
violation of my rights you know and or
completely pooping them and and it does
seem to me that comedy is not you know
the world of comedy is not reflecting
both sides of that argument at the
moment you know so to the extent that
these arguments are taking place on the
fringes at all there is an awful lot of
comedy which doesn't concern itself with
these sort of things at all you know and
that's that's fine but it is interesting
for instance and this is not a slam dunk
argument but just one kind of symptom
Mock the week traditionally you'll have
six comedians on their door O'Brien I
know for instance I hope they won't mind
me saying so Gary Delaney for instance
is at least centrist I would say a
little bit right to center with his
politics and is quite interested in
libertarian ideas he's quite interested
investing in gold because he believes
that fiat currency is potentially he
just does terrific his ponzi strokes are
fantastic and that is his stock in trade
but none of them have that subtext they
are all just kind of you know like kind
of slightly off-color references to
sexual peccadilloes or whatever Milton
Jones another one again I know his
politics centrist is very intelligent
interesting guy in real life but the
character E plays or Mock the week and
on stage is again basically about
one-liners that are of a craziness you
know whereas the left-leaning comedians
you know if you get somebody on there
like Chris Anderson or whatever when he
used to do it you know who are able to
kind of basically use that that platform
to undermine the notion that you Kip is
a
remote Lisa went with the you know prior
to brexit then that was a remotely
feasible proposition i'll quite
comfortable in expressing their views so
there's a bias to that extent I'm not
saying that there are no right-wing
comedians but the extent to which they
feel the natural Liberty that they feel
that their license is granted to express
those views and that of course then
drives the audience in a certain
direction and audiences and it's not I
don't think insulting toward it sister
services it's just you can be part of
this audience yourself but the dynamics
of audiences are that they coalesce into
a single body I mean that's sort of what
the job of the compare is in a comedy
club is to kind of get them into a heard
like format for themselves independently
is that funny making a decision then you
know it becomes very choppy you know and
you do get heckling of course at that
point because people feel quite capable
of speaking against the the grain of the
of the crowd so you need that and of
course if the audience is being you know
driven along you know the the drove way
in a in a certain direction and then one
comedian stands up and goes no that way
you know you don't get the same laugh
because you're not keeping the flywheel
spinning you know you're putting a
spanner in the works and that's a very
different dynamic in any it can be
exciting you know and if you're a
terrific comedian if you were a George
Carlin and you were invited onto that
show and you had the confidence and the
and the vocabulary to you know expose
the political orthodoxes and there's the
Colonus of the views being you know
expressed for what they are then you
could potentially create you know
milestone television but the the chances
are you it will just everyone will go
that's what this is since that doesn't
work that's not what we thought we were
all believed you know and it all just
sort of Peters to a halt but isn't that
the role of the comedian yes it should
be shouldn't it yeah you would well I
mean the comedians work in a number of
different formats it's not necessarily
the role of the panel game I mean the
role of Mock the week you know I think
it's realistic to say is to entertain
people and it does a tremendously good
job the joke rate is ferocious you know
the number of laughs per minute you get
on a show like what the week it sort of
almost killed the sitcom
really you know those you know they were
very very very funny you know you get
and of course then all those comedians
bantering among each other creates a
sort of nice you kind of want to be part
of that gang you know so that's what
that show is forged that shows job to
challenge even though it might like to
wear the clothes of like you know you
know there is the job but yes to be a
George Carlin you know to really stand
up and tear down all the sacred idols
not just the not just those of the right
or the left you know he was every bit as
much an enemy of the the sacred idols of
the of the left you know a lot of hits
took that many of his famous is
quotation was at political correctness
is fascism pretending to be politeness
something like that you know he because
it was quite ani the whole time he went
into his 60s and 70s but nowadays the
opportunities to get in front of an
audience and say that kind of stuff are
fewer you know somebody like Stuart Lee
has he's you know those shows were
tremendous in which he unpacks a lot of
the subtext of a Richard Littlejohn
article or whatever you know and that's
very effective and he's a very good
community it's a very intelligent guy
and he takes his time and he trusts the
audience to come with him on a journey
and I don't want to see the back of him
by any means I just think it would be
quite useful to have the right-wing
equivalent of that but there is a sort
of presumption now partly I think to be
honest you know reinforced by things
that's truly said you know that it's not
it just couldn't be that there is no I
couldn't have a right-wing intelligent
comment you know because because the
right-wing is the voice of privilege and
the voice of power and so that's just
nonsense it isn't at all the right-wing
can be the voice of tradition who are
being trampled at the moment you know
traditions are being are being
obliterated you know anyone for instance
who has a traditional view of gender sex
and and what it is to be a man or woman
their views are currently literally
unsaleable on the BBC you can actually
be you know held up and arraigned in in
the court of public opinion for having
the view that a man is what is a
biological man now that is a traditional
point of view and whether or not it's
right or not
it's a point of view which somebody
should be able to express without
feeling
anxious I would have thought you know
and yet and that is no longer the case
so having the idea that the right-wing
comedian is essentially the voice of the
bank that's just nonsense you know that
isn't what right-wing comedy is
right-wing comedy can be any number of
things it could be like expressing the
views of GK Chesterton you know or
expressing the views of Roger Kipling
you know these kind of and these people
were very funny you know but they
essentially had a tragic view of the
essence of human nature is fundamentally
Unseld saleable and you know progress
being necessarily contingent to
something but increasingly now as well
it could just be the voice of the
socially conservative people yeah it's
just working-class people
yes exactly and it's interesting as you
were talking there one of the things I
was thinking about is the most
successful right-wing comedian in this
country now is Jeff Norka yes and Jeff
is very mild in his right-wing ya know
what I'm saying
yes he's someone who can take a whole
audience along with him even if they are
left-wing yeah which is great he's a
very skilled comedian but you don't have
someone who is slaying the sacred cows
over the left no in the same way that
steward Lee would would do to the right
no and he doesn't dismantle at the same
extent his you're right he's very good
and he's nailed what he is and you're
right it's socially conservative he's
probably I guess it's that old grid
isn't it and so in economic terms he's
probably still on the you know the old
traditional you know my old man's a
dustman that kind of mentality basically
who have been abandoned of course if you
look on that grid and how the MPs in the
House of Commons they are all in that in
the the quarter from sort of midday
around to 9:00 p.m. nobody is in that
top left quarter which is like left-wing
fiscally but but socially conservative
and that is a huge massive slice of the
British public who have felt neglected
and arguably voting for brexit just to
express their discontent with the status
quo you know regardless of whether they
felt they'd properly identified its
route and voted brexit part in the
elections labor versus turn around and
calling them racist but anyway yeah this
is Labour's massive problem now is of
course the Tories have massive problem
super the Labour's massive problem is
that they're trying to split between the
those two massively opposing camps they
had in the post-war consensus managed to
come
buying that to create a coalition of the
socially conservative and the more sort
of intellectual you know degree you know
the credentialism of like left-wing
thought you know that that but has
different views and and wants to lift
depression from increasingly more sort
of narrowly defined intersectional
groups so we what we're talking about is
very very interesting because you know
we're saying that there's no figure on
the right and do you think it's because
comedians self-centered because they go
if I'm actually gonna be honest about
what I think and what I believe my
career will be stunted and could tailed
as a result I think it's perfectly
conceivable that such a comedian exists
yes I don't know how often how many way
in part of the problem is of course that
you don't see them but it might be of
course that you that sort of person is
not good comedy now yeah they might
think I mean and they're playing people
like yourself who were able to blog you
know and it's not quite the same as
being on live at the Apollo but you know
you can you can make look at Andrew draw
for instance he's written that book to
tanni McGrath has become an internet
sensation and he's sold a lot books you
know again he probably won't get the
same sort of TV coverage you know but he
certainly angered the left you know they
are some of them are furious there's a
guy the assistant editor of the New
Statesman I think this Georgie alleged
Georgie but John le GI one might have
his job title wrong but fairly senior
figure there who said I will block
anyone who retweets that account you
know and he wasn't joking I mean he
sounded like absurdly you might say
snowflake but he is basically
threatening people with losing access to
a senior figure in the political
journalist you know of sphere because
they've retweeted a comedy account which
is taking the piss out of left with
orthodoxy so he's obviously you know
he's riled some people which is great
but that's not he would go down that
route you know and there are lots of
other things you could do as well of
course and other people might say you
know yes the right wing you know they
are they're not struggling as much as
you think and they you have this whole
intellectual darkweb thing which is an
hilarious very interesting for I mean
I've been following Jordan Peterson for
many years and I think he's a tremendous
live speaker really compelling because
he's he's thinking in real time and he's
addressing real problems and trying to
use his intelligence
his store of knowledge to produce
coherent answers to real questions you
know that I find interesting in itself
it's not because it necessarily because
he's you know I didn't even really
register that he was that conservative
we need to begin if I see it now but
some of the people who grab that
gathered around him I think are more
opportunist Dave Rubin for instance who
runs this kind of very successful
podcast very possibly a sort of template
for what you guys are trying to do here
I mean he gets like a million hits per
show or whatever it's a very very
successful format but I'm not sure
whether his heart is quite as much in
the in the advancement of human
knowledge so much as it is in the
advancement of Dave
[Laughter]
blame anyone if you manage to crack it
it was like ten years ago twenty years
ago every trip to British chat show
going to be Letterman right yeah
Jonathan Ross wanted to be Letterman and
eventually sort of basically cracked it
but for a lot of them went through it
and Jonathan Ross had a couple of
misfires as well and Johnny fallin and
so on nowadays I think everyone looks at
it I do - I'd like to be Joe Rogan who I
think is lead with the real deal and I
think Dave Rubin is a smart enough guy
but I think there is a little bit of
kind of he likes to sell the whole I'm
heretical you know I'm heterodox thing a
little bit hard where Joe Rogan just
gets on and does it but I mean Joe Rogan
is probably the single biggest chat show
in in the world right now you know it's
probably bigger than Leno or I don't
even know if Leno still is one is it or
you know most of them like Jimmy Lindsey
oh yeah exactly they're very they're
showbiz they're part of the showbiz you
know process everyone comes on it's like
Graham Norton they're very enjoyable you
get to see your favorite stars laughing
and telling slightly off-color jokes but
it's all part of the promotional package
isn't it where is totally totally fake
absolutely and everything is judged you
know in terms of numbers Joe Rogan is
like creating some of the most
compelling conversations that are
happening right now and talking to real
intellectuals and the fact that the guys
is an MMA commentator turned stand-up
comedian who mainly but you know will
happily talk about his testosterone
supplements and and going elk hunting
with it with a bath
he's a fascinating character you know so
that is I mean there is that option and
those guys nobody goes on there is at
all afraid of speaking their mind and
aggressive right wing left wing and Joe
will call them on it if it's [ __ ]
yes that's the great thing Joe is
intelligent enough to go I hope that's
true you know I think actually if you
look at the figures it's been net
migration across the border in the other
way or whatever you know we don't know
them if they come on with their but you
know it's just a there's quite a small
traditional platform in the UK I say
traditional in that over the last 20
years or whatever for stand-up comedians
to operate within and within that I
think there is a bit of gate even going
on yes I do think and that is partly
because if you run a club or run a show
it helps if the audience know roughly
what they're gonna get I'm afraid and
the idea that people like having their
views challenged in comedy I'm afraid is
afraid that's a fairy tale people like
having their views reinforced they laugh
much harder when something they already
think is demonstrated is true in a
fictional anecdote with a punchline yes
that is absolutely true
and how much do you think the error for
a festival plays into this and professor
ball which is home to the you know the
white upper-middle classes yeah you know
lefty liberal yeah but also it is
heterodox in the sense that people come
in from all around the world and also
American tourists have always been
important yeah usually the the weather
the books palace' the internet professor
is often to do with whether we had good
relations with America in this sort of
year building out to it really whatever
you know well after for instance after
9/11 there was a serious plummet because
so they were all afraid of flying
literally or of European terrorism and
every time there's a serious outrage you
know that kind and Americans I think are
a little bit less I think you know
middle-aged Americans are quite happy to
go and see a heterodox views and
actually funnily enough although we
think of Americans as being more sort of
stupid and more you know feedlot
mentality but actually there there's a
libertarian streak in American comedy
and they can support I mean like Bill
burr who would probably be my absolute
hero in terms of just like saying it
like he sees it and I'm not giving a
damn how it's taken and he's now playing
stadiums I don't I think I'd be
surprised if the bill Burke had emerged
from Essex you know which is he's not a
New Yorker is I think he's from yeah
yeah he's got that kind of whammy paint
okay no you know it's not like a
mellifluous who's not like
you know he's a powerhouse he's an
amazing comic and he is prepared to go
places where very few others are and
then he takes you with him because it's
all vulnerable and because he has that
whiny voice and he sounds like he's
probably getting put upon and he's
probably made some dumb choices in his
time himself you know
it's hard to picture him going back to a
really plush pad or whatever you know
even though he sure can't afford one now
so you know I think there's people like
that come out of America you know
somewhat to where we had 20 years when
we were producing you know it was a bit
it's a bit like rock music in the 60s I
think you know the America and Great
Britain are always the Great Sea soaring
entities of these things you know you
there was that period when British rock
music ruled America obviously
Beatlemania and the stones you know and
then they came back with Creedence but
then in the 70s we had Pink Floyd and
Led Zeppelin Zeppelin were easily the
biggest band in America motion thought
they were American you know they were so
massive there you know and again it's
happened with with comedy we had some
really great years you know Eddie Izzard
and Harry Hill and there were some
really creative voices you know but I
think at the moment possibly more
creative stuff more honest truthful
stuff is is possibly and you said that
you couldn't imagine a Bill burr coming
from the UK why is that Simon I can't
imagine him being accepted as as much
you know I mean he is a really
singularly talented individual you know
so maybe if somebody that good and that
honest and that with you know as there's
a saying you know not giving a damn what
people think is a superpower and I think
there's some real truth in that if you
genuinely don't care and you this is
your truth and you're gonna tell it you
know that really will just dissolve a
lot of doors that you might have thought
were shut but I have you know it's been
some time you know and I haven't seen
one I haven't seen many that really kind
of come out you know fighting on that
side you know the idea that I guess they
would call it red pill you know in short
terms you know just pushing back against
the idea that men white white men have
all the you know have all the cards and
have all the oppression opportunities
and and none of the burden you know and
he's just kicking back against that well
I mean that is that is probably
unorthodox of them but you're going to
get crushed if you do that on the comedy
circuit in this country as a newer
comedian yeah
you have to be really strong and really
and really you know care yeah yeah I
mean I guess in you might say the
strongest similarity would be Andrew
Lawrence who was who was brave enough
and also incidentally ginger he hasn't
yeah he hasn't had I mean he tours and I
think he does okay and he did not give a
damn I think when he produced his famous
Facebook screed he ill-advisedly
conflated some genuine concerns with
some random ad homonyms that didn't help
his case and alienated a lot of
potential allies you know and made it
impossible for a lot of us to say I
think he's right there I think he's
wrong there cuz you just don't want to
you know if you touch that kind of stuff
it's toxic at that point you know I feel
a bit sorry for him in that respect but
a lot of what he said you know chimed a
lot of what he said did sound like a bit
of Brandt from somebody who was blaming
everyone but himself for a failure to
enjoy that I mean a lot of people have
had those moments where they think their
career is gonna really take off and then
it doesn't i remember adam bloom for
instance i hope you won't mind me saying
this because i've talked to him about it
there were a few years at edinburgh when
we thought adam bloom would be like a
household name worldwide you know and
then things level off a bit and you have
to adapt to that and accept you know the
new reality and work around it and I
think Andrew Lawrence had a little bit
of that when you started possibly and
then didn't you know and then it's quite
easy to kind of go why am I not on every
show you know that's the trouble when
there are now loads of comedians and
loads of panel games you you have to
avoid that kind of actors mentality
every actor you know there's like ten
actors for every job you know probably
30 or 40 for every good job and it's
really a challenge if you want to make a
living as an actor not to be kind why
isn't at me why didn't that you know
because that kind of stuff just eats
into the soul so there was always that
though there was a little bit of
contamination from that thinking I think
but yeah I mean I know the trouble is of
course with the show like unleash which
as you say I'm gonna I'm gonna headline
out but there is a danger with that that
it becomes this kind of you know or
we're dangerous we're ready and then
everyone goes and it's like but it's not
really it's just to show where we're
comedians feel less policed than they
might do but that doesn't necessarily
mean they're going to run
stage and start you know I was that
danger that kind of bill Grundy Sex
Pistols interview where he goes gone and
say something rude you want to mean any
you nasty [ __ ] or whatever it was you
know this is kind of God you know is
this what this all it is you know that's
not what I'm least is it all know the
thing with unleashed is the whole point
of it is just you don't self-censor
exactly yes something is funny yeah and
that's what we do I mean we go and say
you funny we don't go in there to preach
our political life exactly right yeah
[Laughter]
well yes you're on you aren't censored
and that's good but if you find yourself
uncensored and then you find yourself
not being that transgressive anyway but
funny yeah that's still fine isn't it
is that's it's the capacity of people to
miss it to willfully misinterpret it as
this kind of a wild and crazy we don't
care what we think you know and then of
course there's going to be a an
anti-climax because you know what how
can you live up to that is but but
really what you're saying should be the
norm that's the point isn't it that's
what comedy come up should be that
should be the default method you know
and there should be one or two comedy
clubs where they say if you are a
slightly nervous disposition and without
missing meaning to you know misuse the
word if you might be triggered by a
reference to a sexual assault then this
is the sort of comedy club where you can
go and I assure you it's gonna be you
know all the material has been vetted
and you're not going to encounter
anything that is I don't actually have a
problem with that if that's what people
want I think that's fine what I've
always I think the distinction is that
you are not allowed to impose that rule
across a university campus and say no
event is to take place here which might
trigger anyone who has been given a
warning that that might be triggering to
them and and is told to keep awake do
you want to mean that's the difference
you know I don't have any problem with
safe spaces within a larger space where
you're entitled to go and you know I
don't think I wouldn't advise my
children if they went to university to
to avoid encountering views that they
might find challenging but you know I
might say to them yeah I might say to my
daughter don't necessarily try and
inveigle your way into the Rugby Club
you know and because you might find some
of their jokes
a bit you know disrespectful
I think guys are allowed to have a space
where there also is a safe space for
them to just let off traditional see if
it gets out of hand you know I don't
know I mean I just don't feel like it's
for me to police that kind of stuff no
you need to get but he's interesting on
your bill burr point I was actually
thinking that I love Bill burr I'm a
huge fan of Bill burr he is relatively
unknown in the UK actually he can sell
well when he comes but it's not people
don't use his name no no what I'm saying
is lots of us know him yeah and we might
go and see a show and pay 50 quid for a
ticket and bring five friends but if you
say to an ordinary person who's not a
comedy aficionado in this country
Michael McIntyre everyone knows who he
is yeah if you say to them bill burr no
one does which American comedian see
that they get Chris Rock yeah Chris
Chris Rock Dave Chappelle Dave Chappelle
yeah so and he's very good both days in
fact funny enough Chris Rock I mean this
is a really good example I want to Chris
Rock's most recent show what was it
called had a funny name like a windmill
or something yeah remember one I mean
yes I know the one you mean widest
Copeland yeah he's named after a sort of
childhood toy type thing yeah anyway
really good show I thought well really
good I would buy Chris Rock's you know
highly elevated standards I would say it
was a medium to good show but by almost
anybody else's standards it would be
tremendous but he got away with stuff
that I would never be able to get away
with and no white comedian would be able
to get away with in this country in
terms of sexual politics not in terms of
race obviously you've got away with
stuff in terms of race you know because
that's that is the deal and that I
completely signup to but also he can
kind of go if a guy has a new girlfriend
his friends will say what does she look
like if a girl has a new boyfriend her
friends will say what does he earn what
does he do now that is well you can say
whether that's funny or not that's a
subjective choice but there is no way a
white comedian would get away with that
really he thinks I don't think so no no
absolutely different standards there
definitely and I don't it may just be
because he's of these the context of his
own personal hinterland and his
reputation for telling it like it is you
know but I think there's a lot more I
mean maybe I'll get into trouble for
saying this I don't know but
I think there is a lot more willingness
within the black community to be
realistic about small-scale sexual
politics not like in the workplace but
just like what relationships are like
whereas white liberal orthodoxy about
not like uttering anything that might
suggest that there is any sexual
dimorphism in Psychological terms it's
like I think this lockwood did it really
well I don't begrudge him his I'm glad
he did it you know I I guess I feel is
even broader than that like what one of
the things I talk about on stage is
someone saying to me go back to Russia
you package a [ __ ] apologize and I
have dark skin and I talked about this
in my set and usually it goes down very
well especially in Kent
but but seriously though it's it's
almost oh if there is any tension in the
room it's never from the ethnic
minorities no it's never the Asian
people it's never the black people
they're always laughing because they
recognize they're ridiculous
but also the truth and let's break the
tension right what they want
yeah but it's always the white middle
class liberal people speaking on other
people begin taking offense another
class yeah I mean we've been clued about
this for God it feels at least like a
decade this has been a phenomenon right
people take on other people's behalf at
least I don't know how long no I just
became aware of it over a far shorter
period of time at least a decade I've
known that in America more as well but
yeah that the liberal thing is to take
offense on other people's behalf
definitely yeah I think I don't know
it's very interesting there is a book
called the suicide of the West I know
there are at least three books called
the suicide of the West so I discovered
the other two when a recent one came out
the recent one is by a guy called Jonah
Goldberg who is its guess a right wing
but it's in proper you know seriously
not like remotely foaming he writes for
National Review but he's a nice guy he
was talking about the collapsing of
confidence in I guess what the values of
Western civilization such as democracy
and free thought so and then I went on
to Amazon to see whether to buy this
book and there are other older ones and
it's interesting it's one of those
things that people have been called
for a long time then you know the
suicide of the West have we lost
confidence as a civilization and the
first one was written by a guy called
James Burnham who was originally like a
Trotskyite in the 30s in American
Trotsky I I think he was anyway
certainly settled there eventually and
then and then switched over to the right
you know in the post-war era and and
wrote this book in about 1948 or
something like that basically around the
time of the foundation of the United
Nations and essentially analyzing the
world political drift in terms of the
loss of confidence of the West against
communism at that point there was no
mention of Islam of course which is
nowadays seen as the the the you know
the growing in confidence thing and it's
really interesting because you just see
the same arguments coming out there you
know in the same concerns and he
actually his analysis is very cool it's
well written and he essentially sees it
as he sees liberal politics as a way of
post rationalizing the decline of the
West so he doesn't really see it as
causing the decline of the West he sees
it as the symptoms of it and he sees it
a way of liberals understanding their
loss of power in terms of a deliberate
choice on their part to share that power
so rather than kind of going we are
losing strength we are losing the
argument we are losing the will to
conquer and to win these arguments
worldwide rather we would rather engage
in the kind of pluralism and a kind of
moral relativism which allows us to
understand what is happening in the
world as something other than an abject
defeat which is really interesting you
know and it's a really good book I
recommend it but it's I mean it's almost
like that's you know those things that
go all the way back to Socrates kids
today they got no respect you know
that's you know those things are eternal
it's a bit like that
but I'm not saying it's not true either
so he would he identified that you know
as people taking offense on other
peoples you know yeah absolutely and
there there are many great thinkers
Thomas Sowell is probably the single
strongest voice on in african-american
sort of thinking for me on that front
you know and he just has no no it is
it's refreshing when you see people like
that because I think as we talk about
orthodoxy yeah that is the orthodoxy of
our time yes certainly in a comedy
scene or comedy environment in a comedy
club that is very much the way of
thinking yeah yeah and an audience
afraid to laugh analysis has been done
of audiences you know using cameras and
microphones and so on to see who lasts
first and where and when and there are
certain people within an audience who
seem to give the rest of the audience
permission to laugh and I've noticed
this doing corporates which is corporate
the corporates is a slightly heightened
environment in that respect and also of
course you have total control because
there's no compare there's no earlier
actions taken in this direction or that
direction you're taking a an audience
fresh all they've heard previously is
some announcements about you know who's
one session session award or whatever
and and you quite quickly have to
identify who might who in the room might
be the guys or very often if it's a
mixed audience the women are more likely
to have control over giving permission
to the men to laugh that is a proven
fact in in red research I think there's
a University of Kent that actually
conducted quite a significant you know
experiment within the Comedy Store and
played like regular comedy clubs as well
that many many more times
the men would glance quickly at their
wives or girlfriends to see if they were
laughing and enjoying it a comedian
before they could start to laugh and if
they thought they wouldn't check on
every joke but at the beginning once
you've got the core proposition of this
comedian is this guy okay yeah okay we
like him you know there was a little bit
of nervousness on that front you know
it's obviously you today and so why is
that why is the balance of power is it
that the woman is later going to be able
to withhold sex because something else
it might be that he just doesn't have
the confidence to know whether he's
going to make an ass of himself by
laughing at this guy because he might
trust her to be more intelligent or to
be more emotionally intelligent which i
think is a perfectly reasonable
alternative and slightly less
transactional anyway in corporates you
get them in you and they're very often
the boss you know and if the boss sits
at the front table and often he'll come
and go anyway now it's an entertainment
for you a very funny man
snow Simon Simon Elin Simon Evan Jess
you all have heard of him of course you
know and it's a terrible introduction
and he'll then sit down and then fall
asleep you know or just sit there
looking stonyface to every remote you
mate and of course this quickly sweeps
around the room you know that this guy
if he makes if you guys let's have a
real treat for you now I listen to this
guy on the radio all the time is one of
my absolute favorites and I think you're
going to enjoy - please welcome Simon
Evans and he sits down there and start
roaring with laughter the whole room
goes up and I wish I could say to them
you know explicitly do that one way is
to speak to them of course and and get
them engaged and let at least the
audience know that they're happy with
that and T's a minute I tell he was a
past master I think Dominick Holland who
is again a guy who doesn't get as much
air time as he used to or deserves in my
view but he's made a very good career
making himself known as somebody who is
a very safe pair of hands in in a
corporate setting and he has that way of
just gently mocking the brass you know
the the higher-ranked he will just
gently mock them enough for the audience
to laugh but not so that they'll kind of
mind you don't don't make Sonny
spider-man I we've got about 15 minutes
left Simon I wanted to ask you about
there's this concept for anyone who is
not a comedy kind of aficionado there's
this concept of punching up and punching
down yeah and just to briefly to break
it down at least this is my
understanding
punching up is when you're making jokes
about the powerful like the boss yes
example or straight white men who has
come a fitting the to comfort saturos to
comfort the afflicted and afflict the
comfortable right yes and punching down
would be you know straight why mind
making fun of a disabled woman yeah
right that and and this is the the
number one way of judging comedy yes
which requires you to be familiar with
intersectional but even if you are
familiar with them it strikes me that
there's quite a contradiction there
because for example a straight white
middle-class Etonian old Etonian
university-educated man yeah punching
Doris from Macclesfield
yeah for being racist for voting break
sir that's considered punching up at the
racist
Doris from Macclesfield yes even though
on the intersection intersectionality
scale I mean I don't understand who's
more vulnerable than
than pension Gordon Brown in the back of
a cab referring to a bigoted woman was
that was that punching up or punching
down it's good question isn't it that's
almost that was almost the question I
think yeah it wasn't yeah I mean I was
on a Jeff know podcast recently we
talked about this I think it's a I know
Chris Rock I think originated the phrase
to defy to try and explain how he felt
comfortable doing it I don't think he
ever in turn intended to make this too
deep you know the metric by which all
other comedians are judged but for me in
my routines I like to present a boxing
match that's what I was saying to Jeff
and I said it in real-time and on
reflection I'm sticking with it like
what am i more kind of like my wife
refers it to my hate crime material you
know when I start doing stuff that it's
like might be sounded like it was
punching down I do a routine it starts
with a joke about three men in a
hospital there to collect their baby
confusion and then the punchline is one
of those two in there is Welsh and I'm
not taking any chances right so the joke
is at the expense of the Welsh it's a
big relief because the other man in the
joke was a Pakistani and so you're going
oh well God at least it wasn't yeah so
that plays with people I think it plays
with people's sensibilities already
because you're going oh it's alright
because it's the world she's anything
then in the course of the kind of
aftershocks because I always think once
you've got a good punch line up you need
to kind of like try and you know follow
it up with with the stoppers I like to
think it swings back and forth you know
I described interactions I've had with
Welsh audiences where I've come off the
worst or where I've suddenly woken up to
their trenchant hostility towards a
middle-class Englishman you know it
swings back and forth I may get the
upper hand but it's a proper it's a
match
John I mean I'm the victim in one line
and then in the next line I come back
again you know now that and I did the
same thing more historically with jordiz
again there's a kind of you know I'm
laughing at nothing and it's I mean it's
very the actual basic material is is
very stereotypical that they tend to be
indifferent to cold weather that was
that was it really that they just don't
wear jackets I mean that's the most
route one observation about daughters
but you just stay with it long enough
and see if you can't get something new
out of it
half the jokes I hope were at the
expense of my sort of befuddled slightly
Michael Palin desk you know
would be tolerant and you know curious
traveler in foreign lands trying to
understand the culture of these people
and treating them as if they were some
remote tribe or something whereas in
fact they're part of the United Kingdom
so this is a that's the thing it's
supposed to swing back and forth if
you're relentlessly punching up or down
you are still just relentlessly punching
someone no they have to get the odd
punch back and I think that's the key
and then it doesn't matter so much you
know and then you don't have to start
getting your intersection Olympic tables
you know whether this was a an
acceptable victim but but there are you
ever filled times especially when you
were doing so for instance a sort of
classic you know woke audience yeah that
you find yourself censoring going this
joke I stand by it there's nothing wrong
with it but I simply can't do it because
I know that I'm gonna lose them I would
I would do a joke if I knew that the
joke was good but what will happen if I
sense that they're significantly left in
my views and are finding their sound
comfortable is what will dry up is the
little witty off-the-cuff asides and and
in the moment toppers and an extras
which are actually that's a real shame
because that is what really makes a geek
you know those little asides of what why
an Edinburgh show will start you know on
the first of August with maybe thirty or
forty good laughs and hopefully have a
couple of hundred good laughs by the end
of it because each time you add a little
thing that you think of at the moment
you know all the good writing happens on
stage and if you've got an audience that
you feel is hostile to your core
proposition then you're not going to be
doing any good writing on stage unless
you decide to go [ __ ] you speaking I
don't want people who paint might need
to come to a comedy show to have their
faces ground into my you know person
because I'm not even sure that I'm right
of course you know it's all just for a
laugh so yes you'll try and steer it
away to stuff that we can all laugh
about you know but it is a shame if you
get that and sometimes only one or two
people again policing the audience an
audible sharp intake of breath and I
really detest that because that isn't
actually an honest expression of your of
your reaction it's an attempt to stop
everyone else enjoying this you want to
mean if you play if you if you do an
ordeal for instance I might do a show I
did one recently in home for
oh [ __ ] we win really well it was
absolutely delighted but it was like one
of the last dates of my genius tour one
of the sort of aftershocks and they were
a really good audience but there was
just one line when I made a joke at the
expense of the north/south divide and
the kind of failure of communication but
somebody in the audience sort of
attempted to take it as if I was just
insulting Yorkshire as if I was
condescending to your check you know
seriously rather than ironically and did
that kind of and luckily the rest of the
audience went that was a joke and it was
fine but that's what they were trying to
do even if they weren't consciously
trying to do it that's what that
communicates and that does anger me
because you know nobody needs that in
the room you decide for yourself if you
don't like a joke that's fine but you
start drawing it doing those things and
everyone then starts to feel a little
bit like that not laugh because they
didn't like it and I'm not sure now if
we're on do what I mean and that that's
you know that's that's that can be that
can like slow you down that can freeze
things up and and then you just start to
sort of run on three cylinders instead
of four and it's you kind of policing
yourself all the time and that's no good
I'm gonna ask you because the reason I
brought up the punching up and punching
down thing is that if you're someone who
is a great example of brilliant comedy
that is based I mean if you write it
down and you read it out in the cold
light of a morning breakfast show yeah
to to an audience that is woke you you
make jokes that are extremely funny and
I are well delivered yeah and I
delivered with a great sense of irony
and they're hilarious
thank you but if you if you take them
and you take away the context and you
write them down then they are can be
punching that like you had a great
routine about homeless people and the
beard yes yeah yeah and you're right
though I mean I don't know if I would
that was 15 maybe even yes longer years
ago and I don't know whether I would do
that again now yeah though I might get
away with it I don't know I had more
than the exaggerated sort of baffled
upper-class tough kind of persona that I
played that I mean literally sort of in
Tweed you know whatever made that more
obviously funny because it was quite
clear that this man had no idea what
that was going on in the real world and
was you know
it's interested in that homeless chap
over there is vomiting up his breakfast
appears to be wearing the same socks as
I am you know is that kind of you know
picking on some mindless triviality
instead of you have to do that if I were
and as time has gone on I think I'm less
of an exaggerated persona now I think
I'm moving more towards who I really am
[Music]
because it's exhausting to write in
character all the time but also you have
things you actually want to say maybe
that's self-indulgent but as a result I
think some of that earlier material
might sound more cruel now because it
would seem to be me saying it rather
than but then again Stewart Lee has that
defense as well he says even though he's
never played a character he says that
Stewart Lee onstage is nothing like
Stewart Lee really you know yeah and
Stewart lately says the for instance has
this kind of unbridled hostility towards
the ignorant half of his audience you
know most of you don't even get that do
you you know that kind of thing well
that is funny and it works because he is
sort of you know an exaggerated version
of himself but it is still himself and I
am still myself but more you push the
exaggeration the more you can then get
away with the fact that of course he
doesn't mean that because he's well
aware that homelessness is a serious
issue you know he's just presenting the
idea that somebody could be distracted
by this absurd coincidence but Jeanne
old thinks I'm and we've reached this
point now I mean the eye and the
question and constituent pose was
incredibly about it of course it was but
jokes aren't meant to be taken literally
no but they do have subtext and if they
didn't have subtext at all they wouldn't
be as powerful as they are I don't think
it's a better thing that we have
conversation I do think people should
laugh and their default should be to
laugh and take you in good faith and
only after a certain period of time
should you start to think I'm not sure
this comedian is in good faith I think
he genuinely does want to stir up racial
division or disharmony or whatever but
the you've seen Francis I do think it's
it's a good thing that jokes have the
ability to like they have a bit of steel
in them I don't think that's a bad thing
you know I think that's that's part of
what makes the comedy seem very you know
fertile ground for discussion like this
you know if it was just jokes there
would be nothing to talk about would it
I think that's fine I think that's okay
it's just you know overreaction or
whatever or early in my life I played
the
Comedy Store and there was a woman in
the front row I didn't know joke which
I've done dozens of times where I said
my granddad it was based on actually but
I used to refer to him as my neighbor
stand lame was my granddad's father my
neighbor Stan this was a true story
about him used to refer to the next-door
neighbors as the darkest next door and I
said which was a bit offensive and
certainly rather old-fashioned
especially considering their cornish now
in fact they were Portuguese which I
still felt was a bit you know just amuse
me then he called them the [ __ ] you
know even the faintest sort of deviation
from anglo-saxon skin tones but he
wasn't he was a kind gentle who was just
expressing his the views of his
generation anyway this woman on the
front row as soon as I said that [ __ ]
sharp intake of breath audible intake of
breath I said what was the matter and
she went I don't like no we don't like
[ __ ] jokes she just heard the word
darkly and assumed this was a joke about
[ __ ] you know and about them being a
problem or being stupid or something you
know not at the expense of an old man
who's racist views were not only racist
they were incoherent and had no you know
sort of genetic and that I went into it
and took the piss out of her and the
audience came back but there was a sort
of balance you know there was a moment
but like I felt I had to do with that
because if I just gone yeah you're right
sorry I shouldn't do her now you know
then you've lost your confidence she
lost her faith you know the whole look
there from out of that would have
rippled an entire so instead she had to
be you know dealt with cruelly this is
exactly what I was going to ask you a
final question before we ask the very
final question is one of your probably
most known jokes would be jokes about
the joke about your eyes yes right which
I understand you got from a heckler yes
at the at the creek Sunday night up the
creek where it used to be
Malcolm Hardy's most sort of legendary
performances he would you'd have a
decent out in the first half of a decent
act in the final section but in the
middle section was was all open spots
and he'd always go cook at least one
weapon cook might be [ __ ] you know there
was no there was no attempt to big you
up at all and there were a group of guys
I think they were all cab drivers and
they all used to congregate around the
sound booth in the back left-hand corner
section of the room who would just
samurai I mean they were all ninjas I
should say they were devastating
hecklers and they made or broke a number
of careers you know and if you went on
there without the confidence that you
had what it took you know that could be
the end of your career you know they
would dismantle you and that was it but
that was the only one he shouted out
where are your eyes
and hole I had no idea my eyes do
disappear in shadow under stage lighting
in normal conditions they're small but
you can't see where they are but under
stage lights you know the angle comes
down they just look like yeah like holes
like I've been you know gouged and
everyone laughed and I had no idea one I
couldn't get it back from there I've
done about two or three minutes it was
going all right you know not brilliantly
and then that was it and then I just
sort of shuffled off and then afterwards
I was talking to somebody and they said
you know your eyes do disappear maybe
and we agreed that I should do that joke
I should get in there first because then
you have a level of self-awareness the
audience is love audiences love it
that's all the old so-and-so has let
himself go that's the usual joke right
yeah ink out of this life you look a bit
like no I'm looking for that Johnny
famine God for egg was a character in
this life which was an early version of
sort of Steadicam single-camera sort of
it was a lovely sort of comedy-drama
series about people starting out their
postgraduate lives in London and egg was
a very much a serious sort of a bit of a
heartthrob I'm gonna have to do the
research Andrew Lincoln there's all that
thing Stewart Lee again who appears I'm
obsessed with you he had a 10 minute
routine in which he did all the people
that he looked like had let themselves
go from Terry Christian through that the
bloke who used to be in Grange Hill and
then Tucker who then ended up in
EastEnders all these people he looks at
and all of them worked and the audience
would laugh again and again and again
and you just realize he looks like so
many people it's absurd I was an even
better one now I saw him a couple of
weeks ago at the Bill Murray London and
he walked onstage in and when it looks
like Julian Assange's let himself go and
he looks exactly like a fat version of
Jesus he has white hair and he's got the
white hair and Samantha beard he's got
the whole look I reckon he's probably
cultivated it just for that one job
yeah yeah so but the reason I bring up
that but anyway I tell you just win
there must be at least ten years later I
was in a cab and as I went to pay the
blows you know comedian Tanya and I went
yeah he goes I saw you years ago I don't
you remember me i heckled you the back
of the or up the creek where your eyes
and and he was the one who done that and
I I mean that was the opening routine I
used on Mike Michael McIntyre's road
show that was like my my first properly
televised you know yeah I had to give
him a very healthy but the reason I
bring it up is that do you think comedy
is possible without an element of
Cruelty even at your own expense even
because this is one of the things that
when I turned down that contract from
Sohus a lot of people were saying well
why do you need to be cruel and I was
kind of saying well look even
self-deprecating comedy yes is cruel I
was the cruelest comedy yes his
self-deprecating comedy do you think
it's possible to to for comedy to be
this place where everyone's just holding
hands and you know no I if you define
cruelty that way I think you're right
there has to be some sort of target even
if it is only the bigotry of those who
were previously free to find something
else is the target you know something
has to get it yeah even Charlie Chaplin
who you know lovable [ __ ]
you know encountering modern technology
and and having I mean there's still the
cruelty there that this is a essentially
one of life's most marginalized people
who has been who can't even manage to
get across the road you know without and
and that is then using his his native
abilities to do so despite his low
socioeconomic status if he was not low
socioeconomic status it wouldn't be so
funny and so there's a kind of cruelty
of like it's not a million miles from
the tenant stroking away it's kind of
going oh well it's alright isn't it
because you know they have this gun you
know yeah I think you do have to have it
but it can be dressed up in all kinds of
different ways and that's what I think a
really good comedy show is is one where
the target moves around so much that
even though at some level you're you're
registering that's you know that there's
some cruelty it's not relentlessly in
pursuit of a single objective
although that again can be funny if you
overdo it so obviously again with my
Welsh routine I would do it it will
become
bit too long I was nagging on a nerve
there we go anyway time to move on
although I will say this you kind of get
you know funny again but yeah you have
to move it around and and that's where
self-deprecating comedy is an essential
part of any remotely long set because
it's sometimes you have to switch it
around again it comes back at you and
this is why it becomes as I said a
boxing match rather than boxing like you
know punching up or punching down it's
still just punching you have to take the
punches as well and you know rocky was
right on that front you know essentially
at the end of the day life is about how
many punches you can take rather than
how many you use you know it's how many
times you can get up rather than how
many times you can knock someone else
down that I think is probably you know
as as as profound a lesson as you can
learn through the course of your life
that that's what it takes you know and
that's often quite literally what the
best boxers have it turns out as well
powerfully-built skulls that can take
pounding rather rather than all being in
the biceps and the hips and that's a
massive part of being a decent comedian
any comedian who looks remotely
thin-skinned themselves that is that is
the death that is the end if you if you
yourself are thin-skinned about comedy
and there are one or two people who sort
of pop up frequently on various you know
television opportunities to discuss
comedy matters who are who to my mind
dude image you know who speak for the
industry but are themselves it's in
skinned in my view I'm not going to name
names but I'm short so I know so someone
who might have called me a Nazi a while
back it's just the death of company for
me once you reach that point I am really
happy with how this episode I'm gonna
bear the brunt of this for the next six
months so Thank You Simon but the last
question we always ask our guests which
is what's the one thing people are
talking about aren't talking about that
we really do need to be talking about
right in comedy or whatever it wouldn't
be one thing well funnily enough I had a
conversation with a friend this morning
I said with a friend in London and and
this was the chat we had in over coffee
is
that we are all living longer and nobody
is paying very much attention to what to
do with the final third of your life my
father is 89 years old now and he sort
of retired he took sort of necessary
retirement essentially mid 50s so he has
spent over 30 years of his life in his
post work environment and yet there's
almost no discussion about how to make
he personally is a very resourceful
individual who bought wood turning lathe
he has a kiln these use until quite
recently as all sorts of hobbies and
crafts and he keeps himself active and
is not just slumped in front of the
television for that time at all but you
know that is a serious issue and I'm 54
now that's the age at which he lost his
job and was deemed you know unemployable
again essentially you know man at that
age with no qualifications very hard to
find work in in the midst of a recession
as it was then so that's an issue which
I'm sort of think about now you know
what how do you make sense at the final
third of life we are all we have
available to us all the medications that
will keep us alive they'll keep us
ticking over you know you see anyone in
their ages has a pillbox you know with
all the dates and the times and that you
know without which they would probably
be dead but they're not dead they need
they need to be we need to find ways to
occupy them and ideally even to make
them economically productive you know I
know that sounds harsh but if you've got
a you know half your population or our
post economic productivity that is not
something that any nation can survive
for very long so I think that is the big
issue and it was interesting that
tourism a raised that issue prior to the
2017 general election and it turned out
to be so toxic such a third rail but I
think that's what most of the
essentially most of the election she
didn't emerge from that with the pro
anything like a workable majority I
think she lost the she lost the good
will of that you know those elderly Tory
voters who are always reliable will
always come out wind or shine to do vote
Tory because they feel that the toys
will look after but any suggestion that
we might need to look at the financial
arrangements or the way in which we
approach you know in which a nation
deals with its elderly is
extraordinarily toxic debate it's a very
typical subject now even among those
people themselves talking among
themselves they don't like to discuss it
but we need to address that because
everyone is living much much
longer than they used to be and our
welfare state you know people talk
endlessly about whether migrants or
immigrants are a burden on it or whether
they in fact of course which it the
statistics suggest produce the tax
receipts which allow us to pay for it
you know I think it's it's a very
wrongheaded view I don't want to close
down any conversation about immigration
but there are dozens of ways to talk
about it but in terms of them being a
burden on it I just think that's been
disproved categorically but what is a
burden on it is you know an elderly
population who's whose own mental health
you know is at risk from their from
their inability to engage what will be
productive will be useful and we need
more templates for how they can be how
they can be engaged useful and
constructively in society basically I'm
saying grandmother's should look after
my kids it's I've missed that
opportunity but yeah that that is the
the big conversation or much to have and
then it's it's a very important one so
Simon if someone wants to find you on
Twitter on Instagram
I can't imagine after that voting issue
I am these Simon Evans on Twitter I
visit Instagram about once a year and
very rarely post anything of use but
Twitter is my place share I have a
Facebook page by you spoke first not for
the fans and you are going to be a dead
and professed of all yes tell us where
the show is tell everybody what the show
is called and where it is gonna be it
the Assembly Rooms on George Square
which is sort of down towards the
meadows and I think it's Assembly Room I
think a studio too but I'm not sure
anyway the show is called dressing for
dinner but that's just one of those
names don't worry about that too much
Simon Evans 8 p.m. people take five
minutes at the george square simon as
you will have seen during this interview
is absolutely fantastic comedian make
sure you go and see him if you're in
edinburgh for the festival I'll be there
as well as you know doing all well ends
well Francis is going to be performing
here in London at the Bill Murray do a
couple of times June August because I
[ __ ] hate as always follow us at
trigger pod on all the social media
don't want to drag you this out too long
we will see you in a week from now
absolutely and also as well please leave
us a nice iTunes review tell a friend
about it if you enjoyed it subscribe
also now on bit shoot if you want to
check us out there
yeah thank you very much and we'll see
you next week
bye bye bye bye
[Music]
there is the form that you were asked to
I said by signing this contract this is
a UNICEF on campus SOAs right it was
asked to sign an agreement that his
routine would not contain racism sexism
classism ageism ableism homophobia
biphobia transphobia xenophobia
Islamophobia anti religion nante atheism
I think you're doing some quite
complicated mental arithmetic so that
the people didn't think they were funny
absolutely no human feel like you just I
mean you're just so fing above and out
right you know all right that we got
there in the end you didn't do the good
thing about people the magic needed
right as I now go in each one of them is
I haven't got any racist sexist
homophobic jokes I have been a student
at the University where you can't make
any joke about anything if these
portable hope the students get upset or
drinking get over yourselves
it's not about comedy it's about
ordinary people up and down the country
and here in Britain and in America
feeling like they can't say what they
think I really don't like I get it I get
it especially especially the women who
want to become in right when from
talking to real madrid the guy left a
perfectly good club for more money
everybody feels like we're we're all
kind of under arrest we're all
everything we say can and will be used
against us in the court of public
opinion and can they're coming for the
comedian's first because we're we're the
ones that as you say are allowed to
transgress but everybody else feels it
and that's why the story's got the
resonance though it has
you
[Music]